وصف متحدث باسم منظمه الصحه العالميه
الوضع في قطاع غزه بالصعب جدا واكد ضروره
حمايه مستشفى دير البلح لانه الملاذ
الاخير للمصابين حسب تعبيره وفي مقابله مع
الجزيره اكد المتحدث ان الاوامر التي
تصدرها قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي باخلاء
المناطق المحيطه بالمستشفى تجبر الفرق
الطبيه على التوقف عن العمل وعلى
المغادره هذا السؤال هو نفسه الذي اثاره
مدير مستشفى دير البلح ومفاده انه لابد من
حمايه هذا المستشفى نحن في منظمه الصحه
العالميه يمكننا تقديم المساعدات كمواد
الاغاثه والاسره واللقاحات لكننا بحاجه
لوقف اطلاق النار او ممر انساني يمكننا من
الوصول الى المستشفى تمكنا من الوصول الى
هناك يوم الاحد الماضي وقدمنا بعض
المساعده والادويه لكن لا يمكننا حمايه
المشكله هي انه عندما يطلب اخلاء المناطق
المحيطه بالمستشفى تصبح الفرق الطبيه
مجبره على التوقف عن العمل وحين يكون هناك
اخلاء توجه الناس غالبا الى مناطق
مكتظه